pulling a fast one on studio executives
in alternate reality justin bieber a
hugely successful rapper who never
actually raps on his own show this is
the untold truth of atlanta you would be
justified in thinking that atlanta was
always an easy sell after all donald
glover was pitching it to fx the same
donald glover who helped define 30 rock
in his first three seasons kept
community alive and had already proven
his ability to write whatever he felt
like and spin it into gold and this was
the same fx that had spent the last
decade proving its ability to sniff out
great comedies like it's always sunny in
philadelphia and archer but according to
glover the only way he could get atlanta
past fx execs was to hide it in a trojan
horse as glover told the press backstage
at the 2016 golden globes after atlanta
took home two of the awards i told fx
the show was something it wasn't until
we got there and then hoped it would be
enjoyable glover never specified exactly
what shape the trojan horse took but
given the popular comedies of the day
it's likely he pitched a show about
nothing glover has said that atlanta was
a longtime dream for him and his brother
steven saying that his brother showed
him a letter he'd sent home while he was
in college that said yo i had this dream
where we write a show together when it
came time to pitch the show glover made
sure that his dream came true hiring
steven as a writer executive producer
and co-showrunner for the show's entire
run since the very first episodes of
atlanta steven's presence on the writing
team has consistently proven to be more
than nepotism on glover's part among
many other gems steven penned the show's
hit paper boy rap as well as season
one's acclaimed exploration into
alternate reality nobody beats the biebs
he and glover made the bizarre and
ultimately genius decision to include
real-life figure justin bieber in the
script cast a black actor in the role
and never address it in the episode as
steven told vulture about their choice
it's a good idea because it makes you
ask yourself questions about the way you
perceive justin bieber this is something
we're never going to get to see unless
we do it ourselves
setting it apart from nearly every show
on television atlanta has an all-black
writing staff for a show determined to
represent black american lives
authentically that type of roster is
especially impactful in fact to anyone
outside the industry it may seem like a
no-brainer but it's hard to overstate
how atypical that decision is in
hollywood in recent years a number of
major studies have attempted to
highlight the problem accurately a
famous color of change report from 2017
found that during the
2016-2017 season
65.4 percent of shows had no black
writers on their staff and another 17.3
percent had only one equally as damning
the report found that overall only 4.8
percent of all employed writers were
black so what percent of writer's rooms
are entirely black a number low enough
for examples to make headlines that's
why glover's choice to only hire black
writers made such a splash and the
choice plays an obvious role in
generating and maintaining the show's
exceptional and sometimes uncomfortable
realism glover has explained the
decision time and again not just
invoking the sincerity it enables but
also the insight at one point telling
vulture i wanted to show white people
you don't know everything about black
culture
is a symptom of the way things are
not the way things necessarily should be
it's no secret that glover moonlights as
a musician he is after all a five-time
grammy-winning hip-hop artist but glover
has always been adamant that his show
about a rapper doesn't star himself as
that rapper why not play a rapper you're
you're a rapper go with what you know
that would have been whack to me
he then went on to explain to colbert
how he felt his pre-existing fame would
undercut the show's underdog every man
objectives glover wanted his show to not
only feel authentic but explore the
meaning of authenticity itself so
casting himself as a poor struggling
rapper on the streets of atlanta would
have rendered any ambitions of
authenticity moods as a successful
showrunner however glover understands
efficiency so he does help write the
show's music on occasion like bieber's
forget about it all night long though
atlantic chronicles the potential rise
of fictional rapper paper boy instead of
the actual rise of real-life rapper
childish gambino the rapper's
fingerprints are nonetheless all over
the show for one thing the show's score
comes from composer ludwig gorensen
perhaps best known for winning an
academy award in grammy for his black
panther soundtrack but who also has
produced and acted as
multi-instrumentalist on every one of
childish gambino's albums the pair met
while both were working on nbc's
community and hit it off due to the
quality of childish gambino's music
which goranson has referred to as such
an inspiration in addition to gorenson
glover chose frequent childish gambino
music video director hero mirai to
direct atlanta the director who filmed
the videos for some of gambino's biggest
hits including this is america had never
actually directed tv before which clever
found useful as glover told vulture
about mariah's unusual background i'm
really glad because when i'd asked him
is this normal for a show he'd be like i
have no idea i don't know but that's how
we made something personal in most
episodes of atlanta it's clear that many
of the characters if not all of them are
high for some like darius it can act as
an important facet of their character or
drive their decisions for others like
earn or van it is just a fact of life a
helpful tool for relieving the stress of
life as a working parent who wants more
but the characters of atlanta aren't the
only ones taking the agile it's cast and
crew art too when interviewed by the new
yorker glover who was high during the
interview revealed that in the writers
room and on the set we do everything
high the effortless chaos of atlanta the
moments of enlightenment followed by an
abrupt return to reality is definitely
shaped by weed when glover ran the
scripts for his pilot episode by fx
executives he was met with a specific
pushback that depending on your
experience and outlook is either
inevitable or unbelievable exacts told
him not to use the n-word in the episode
and when glover disputed the constraint
the execs consented to an odd compromise
you actually said that i had to cool
glover resorted to bringing in a
seasoned executive producer paul sims
who had gained a reputation among black
creators as a white translator helping
explain creators visions and necessities
to execs in a language they can relate
to
eventually glover and sims won out and
atlanta has since included the word
liberally in a manner that the cast and
crew feel is appropriate and accurate
that doesn't stop glover from recalling
the linguistic battle with disbelief
telling the new yorker that i'm black
making a very black show and they're
telling me i can't use the n-word only
in a world run by white people would
that happen
there are few creative teams that have
publicly cited a more diverse set of
inspirations than the team behind
atlanta though perhaps that isn't so
surprising given glover's famously
multifaceted nature and the fact that
neither director mirai nor most of the
writing staff had ever created tv before
the rawness and quirkiness of the
atlanta crew are apparent not just in
their finished product but in their
influences as well mirai has cited louis
and adventure time as structural
inspirations for the show especially how
the latter is very world-based sometimes
the main characters won't even appear in
an episode and the story will sort of
detour with some side character glover
told press that season 2 was inspired by
the format of tiny toon adventures how i
spent my summer vacation in his colbert
interview glover likened atlanta to curb
your enthusiasm for rappers and is also
referred to it as twin peaks for rappers
mirai also cited the cullen brothers
ability to deftly balance multiple tones
glover has cited the albums of kanye
west as inspiration admitting to lining
up his seasons as if they were west's
releases
one of the most memorable entries in the
atlantic canon which is saying a lot in
a show where kat williams plays an
alligator man and characters identify as
trans-racial is the season 2 episode
teddy perkins the episode sees darius
trapped in a dimly lit decrepit mansion
with an unsettling vaguely threatening
old man apparently born black but now
white due to an extraordinary amount of
plastic surgery the old man perkins
looks just a touch inhuman right in the
uncanny valley sweet spot his slow
movement and quiet forced speech bring
the episode as close to an actual horror
movie as atlanta had ever ventured up to
that point
wasn't it
go ahead
walk in
perkins was played by glover himself who
went all in on the role staying in
character as perkins for the duration of
filming actor derek haywood who played
perkins elderly brother revealed that
perkins true identity was kept secret
even to fellow actors he told vulture i
was introduced to him the night before
at the fitting but i didn't know it was
donald and obviously he didn't want you
to know
in 2017 atlanta won the golden globe for
best television series musical or comedy
and glover won for best actor in a
television series musical or comedy then
at that year's emmy awards the momentum
continued glover won emmys for
outstanding lead actor in a comedy
series and outstanding directing for a
comedy series the wave of success that
atlanta and glover were riding in
response to their first season was
tremendous and it was also historic
glover's win for directing was the first
time a black person had ever won an emmy
for directing comedy of any kind and as
the los angeles times noted glover was
the first director to win for a show in
which they acted since alan alda won in
1977 awards were not the only bragging
point for atlanta as its pilot set a new
viewership record among basic cable
comedies and it managed to maintain the
majority of its audience throughout its
run when all its rating success is
combined with the peabody it received
for its seamless blend of vibrant
character study and rich socio-political
commentary it becomes clear that atlanta
is more than just your average tv show
fans and critics can't get enough of
atlanta but its creator can despite the
series stellar fan following critical
reception and cultural importance glover
has repeatedly made it clear that
atlanta won't run for long as early as
2018 he was quoted as saying atlanta
won't interest me much longer fx later
made that prediction official announcing
that season 4 would be the last for
atlanta glover explained the decision to
reporters with a lengthy paragraph that
can be easily boiled down to its opening
sentence death is natural as
disappointed as many fans had to have
been when they heard the news those who
have followed glover's career might have
expected an early finale glover is
famous for his short attention span
which caused him to quickly exit 30 rock
and last only slightly longer on
community as former co-star danny poody
recalled glover's talent was so obvious
that his cast mates knew he would move
on almost immediately it's worth
remembering that short attention spans
swing both ways however and the same
restless drive that causes glover to end
projects can easily push him to revisit
them as he told reporters shortly after
his death is natural speech if there's a
reason to come back to atlanta of course
it always depends i like keeping my
options open
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you